there's all these problems uh you went
independent when
the idea of well it was a it was a
couple steps to go independent so i left
a few networks i originally left the
young turks and then i was on aura tv
which was a digital network
then i left there and i was on patreon
and i was kind of the first of the
politics guys to be on patreon it was
mostly gamers
and anime people and i i the reason i
wanted to leave aura tv was a digital
network founded by
my friend and mentor larry king the
reason i wanted to leave
was because our show was blowing up and
in essence i think you'll really like
the story actually because
we we were but there's like larry king
and clary king live larry king larry
we were we were becoming bigger than the
network so we were crushing it and what
was happening was they were taking
resources from our show
in essence to support things that
weren't working and they were constantly
asking us to hit bigger and bigger
metrics and i was like
this doesn't make sense like we're
crushing it we're doing
really good stuff but they're basically
taking from us and and
i mean you get the socialist part of
this so i was like i was like let's just
go
let's try it let's try to do this on our
own see if we can do it build a studio
do the whole thing
took my producer and my director all
quit our jobs salaries
health care the whole thing we launched
on patreon and it was a monday morning
this is this is now around 2016 or so
okay so only five years yeah okay and
this was just the first step in true
independence
and i said to my guys it was sunday
night at like 11 30 we're about to go to
bed just launch it first thing in the
morning i said i may have completely
[ __ ] up our lives
i i like i may have like we're screwed
if this doesn't work
within about 10 minutes the next morning
once we launched
we were at about 30 grand a month and i
was like we're gonna be okay and then
that
really that then and you were pumping it
through social media in terms of like
promoting it
pushed it everywhere i could and people
were people were excited that somebody
was going independent
standing up for what they believe in all
of that kind of stuff
then from there eventually built my own
studio so that was the next part of
being independent i wasn't renting
studio space anymore what you guys have
done here you own this nobody you know
maybe somebody's gonna
you know chop the wire to shut off the
lights but otherwise you know as long as
you pay your bills you're good to go
so that was the next part and then
really what what fully did it was
uh december of 2018 i was uh it was
just about wrapping up you know i toured
with jordan peterson for a year and a
half which was
unfreaking believable i look back on it
like it was a dream we did about 120
shows in 20
countries in a year in essence and you
guys were just talking at the shows
so i did warm up i would do about 15
minutes a crowd warm-up just get
everybody laughing and having a good
time
um then he would give a i mean this guy
is truly incredible like when people
think that this guy's incredible
he would give an hour and a half lecture
a different hour and a half lecture
every night i never heard the guy give
the same speech twice
some wow sometimes he'd be you know his
12 rules for life was the book so
sometimes he would go through all 12
rules
sometimes he would do one rule sometimes
he would do no rules if he was just
angry at the new york times he would do
an hour and a half on that
like literally sometimes he would be
like you know i bumped into somebody
before the show who told me
uh that they're struggling with drug
addiction and then he talked about like
it was
it was truly and the coolest part of it
was that
i would see him push his intellectual
limits
every night and then he would stop like
he would literally be like
he would be talking about something and
then he'd be like you know that's all i
can say about that tonight i'm gonna
think about it a little bit more and
then the next
day he'd start the show by saying you
know last night i was talking about this
and i thought about it today
so i was basically watching a choose
your own adventure i was watching a book
being written throughout the whole thing
anyway uh we're on tour december 2018
and i was on patreon that's where i was
making like i don't know probably 80 or
90
of my company's rev and there was a guy
by the name of carl benjamin sargon of
akata on youtube he was like an old
school british
liberal decent guy he went on another
channel so now not his patreon channel
not his youtube channel that was
being funded on patreon he went on
somebody else's channel and he said the
n-word
now he did not say it to be racist he
was mocking the people who used that
word patreon immediately deleted his
account
this is where he was making most of his
money running a business now they
offered no
chance of respite there was no way he
could talk to them
and to me that was such an like
extraordinary escalation because
it's one thing for a tech company to
police what you're doing on the
with what you do on their site but if
they're basically watching you
watching what you say on other sites now
we that's like
can we go after you for whatever you do
in your personal life so jordan and i
discussed it
and we had both had we were both
friendly-ish at least with uh with carl
carl
uh sargon of god and we both said okay
it's time to leave patreon
and this was a big deal when you guys
left right oh it was i think it was
front page new york times actually yeah
for some reason we didn't know each
other at the time but i i feel like i
remember
it was like a one-two punch almost yeah
and like it'd be
like okay like that's an interesting
data point yeah and then sam harris left
the next day and he was making a ton on
there and then and then a few other
people left
but that is where they where'd they all
go like where'd you go so what happened
so basically so a soft right over there
is my brother-in-law and he's a tech guy
and i called him and i said listen i
want to leave patreon
i need you to put down what you're doing
and build me a subscription model
because that's the first piece
the first piece is i need to be
financially free and just replicate
like the bare bones patreon stuff then i
contacted
um patrick hollison at stripe we had
become friendly a little bit and i said
what is
the best example of a subscription page
that we can basically replicate and
build for me not not locals as a bigger
idea just
solve this problem for me he told us one
soft built it
and then from basically just middle of
december to january
you like how a tech company gets built
well i i just like the fact that you're
like
what's the best one right here the
person who probably knows what the best
one is no that was it i was like i don't
know patrick this is what you do and he
said this is the one and
i said that's the one we're going to
build and to assaf's credit we built it
and basically i used about three weeks
the end of december into january to tell
all of my people that i am deleting
my patreon on january 15th and i am
launching reubenreport.com which
ultimately became the first test model
for locals
and by doing it on that day and i did it
on a live stream i actually deleted it
live stream and i doxed myself like a
[ __ ] because
i didn't realize that when i pressed
delete on the patreon thing my my
personal email was gonna pop up
so i literally doxed myself and i was
drunk because i was doing shots of
patron
in honor of leaving patreon so i'm doing
for so for every thousand dollars i
think that we made
i was gonna do a shot so i literally did
like eight shots of tequila i doxed
myself i mean it was
it was quite a day uh so there's some
less did you know that
did you know that you doxed yourself i
mean you did it
i knew immediately and these people
these sick twisted freaks online i have
been signed up for every porn site you
can imagine people literally paying for
porn for me i mean
these people anyway uh the next day
though
that like that's commitment like when
you literally are like oh i found
someone that i don't like email address
i'm now going to
it's not that they just signed me up for
free sites people literally i was
getting things like here's your password
thank you still use that email it's long
gone it's long gone but but you know
it's hard to get rid of an email address
so like
push you know whatever anyway this is
the cool part and this is what really
was the
the genesis of locals january 15th
closed down patreon
the next morning i woke up and our rev
jumped by about thirty thirty five
percent
from what you're doing so you actually
were making more on day one
yeah you know more on day one and i
wasn't doing rewards so you know patreon
is like tear downs you send them a
t-shirt or you sign things or you do
zoom calls with people
we decided to get rid of all of that if
you want to support
me being independent talking about the
things you care about giving me a chance
to get more interviews out there expand
these ideas
join us we're not doing rewards anymore
so i took away rewards
but it's the bravery thing people want
to support people that they think
are fighting for the things in their
world that they care about it's why
people love you over bitcoin you they
believe in bitcoin and then here you are
freaking screaming about this thing
even in the last couple weeks where it's
been very messy your guys love you even
more because it's become because it now
has more of a cost
for you right it's not at its peak right
now and all that stuff
so we jump by about 35 and then i said
to us off now we got something here
because now well what else would i need
to be free
i can't just be reliant youtube could
shut me down tomorrow right twitter
could shut me down so let's
replicate these things so we said all
right we gotta build
our own video player we gotta build
audio we gotta build a community
a news feed that's unmanipulated by an
algorithm and by the way having a
paywall
there's no trolls there's no bots it's
all good behavior in there and if you
wanna pay me to troll me well now i can
either profit off you
or i boot you out of my locals community
but you could still be in anyone else's
locals community which is very different
because
on twitter if you're booted you're
de-platformed all together
so i think by building something that
was right for me as a creator we have
built something that i think solves
probably 95
of the problems for 95 of the people it
doesn't solve alex jones's problems and
i don't know that i want to be in that
business but and now we have awesome
investors that are
what are his what are his problems well
he can't be on stripe for example so
stripe is our primary payment processor
it's your own stripe account
it's not ours um we get 10
which is the same amount as patreon but
we have a much better product than
patreon because you own all of it you
own the data
you own the users like if you nobody
leaves us but if you leave
it's all yours you can take it with us
if my channel locals has done so well
that if my channel blew up
if youtube just took me out tomorrow man
you talked to pomp you're done
if they took me out tomorrow um my
business is still thriving
like i have for something like 1.6
million subscribers on youtube i make
way more with my thousands of
subscribers on patreon
so i've built a steady model to make
myself uncancelable
and that's what we then were like all
right now we've got a business here
let's let's
twist what are the sponsors so i think
there's a lot of people who are
interested in this some of them are
interested because uh they literally
fear
being cancelled for what they say
there's people who fear the platforms
are just manipulating things there's
people who fear that distribution goes
away
there's people who fear that they will
get caught up by association
right they interview somebody whatever
uh and then there's literally people who
just fear like
chaos you know i did nothing i talked to
nobody like i just have an accountant
that youtube doesn't work either
like just like something bad happened
right um and you see
you know somebody on twitter gets
suspended and they're like i haven't
even tweeted in three days or whatever
and
usually it's like some stupid thing
where uh
um there's a founder that i invested in
this company uh
there was an event that happened in the
world he started to get a bunch of
followers next you know he's suspended
my guess is that literally there's like
an automated system
it looked like spam to them because it
was like an explosion of followers
or something get suspended then but the
point is you don't know
we don't know the problem but but still
just that stuff can happen or whatever
so i guess like when you think about all
of that what are the ingredients to be
quite
independent or like to really be
resilient on the internet today so you
first off you have to have direct access
to your audience
that's number one so when i tell you i
have whatever it is 1.6 million youtube
subscribers
i can't get videos out to them because
the algorithm now
they've decided that you're subscribed
this is just what they've decided at
youtube
your subscribers actually have less
weight now so they they're sending you
videos usually now based on your viewing
habits
which by the way can really pigeonhole
you into a certain political belief or
religious belief or whatever it might be
or for me it's just sending me a lot of
80s basketball and star wars videos
all day long like i'm watching you use
all my you know you know that that's
really the way to get to know somebody
just
look at their youtube history it's like
man i have watched the 1992 nba season
every game backwards and forwards i
don't watch regular basketball anymore i
can't take it because it's all political
and whatever
um but you you want direct communication
with your audience so what we built i
mean the locals app is awesome you get
push notifications
when i post things so that's just one
like you will get my stuff we're not
manipulating it with an algorithm
the news feed is unmanipulated so that's
part and it's uh reverse chronological
so if i
sign in the last thing you posted is
first i can kind of go back and just see
and you can somewhere like a
facebook profile page or something right
and it's
uh you can either filter it if you're in
the rubin report community you can
filter it just by what i'm posting or
we let all our users post and by the way
we're getting something like what's the
number 80
of the content something like 80 of the
content in my
community is from the users not from me
so and what's interesting about that is
they're posting recipes they're posting
music they're posting things about
sports all kinds of stuff
things that they know i like but then
people are sort of coming to social
media in with fresh eyes
because as opposed to you post a pic a
picture or you post a recipe
you know you make chicken parm you post
it on facebook next thing you know your
grandma's fighting with some random
person
about trump and it's like man this all
became evil and now grandma doesn't seem
as nice as grandma's supposed to be and
i don't know who that person is but oh
it turns out i was i went to high school
with them 20 years ago and now and but
it all feels awful
on there we have people coming there's a
common what i want every locals
community to have and this is what they
all have
is you could just come together for some
common cause so
for a guy like you would be okay i love
bitcoin i believe this is the future of
commerce and
the engine that's gonna lead us to the
new world and then people
are like oh pomp's cool like i'm going
to come into this community we're going
to talk about stuff and then what you're
going to find is they're going to start
talking about a lot of other stuff
so it's it's what social media was
supposed to be and again because of the
pay wall
you you get rid of all if if you had a
10 cent paywall
as i said on locals ours i think i said
this year our minimum
is two dollars but if we had a 10 cent
paywall that would eliminate almost all
the bad act